As far as action-packed shows from the 1990s go,
"Xena: Warrior Princess" is one of the
best. Xena, played by Lucy Lawless,
was given her own spin-off after a brief recurring
role in "Hercules: The Legendary Journeys."
Creator Robert Tapert recognized how popular she
was with audiences, and "Xena: Warrior Princess"
quickly became a cult favorite, running
for six seasons from 1995 to 2001.
The swords-and-sandals epic doesn't just have the
hero facing off against evil warlords or Ares,
the God of War, however. Xena often
battles demons and monsters too,
and considering the show was produced in
the 1990s, some of the practical effects
look pretty great. It seems pretty clear that
"Xena" is ripe for a reboot, especially in a
time where "Wonder Woman" made $800 million at
the box office when it debuted back in 2017.
So, why hasn't a "Xena" reboot happened yet?
Unsurprisingly, "Xena" fans have always been
vocal about their love for the hero, especially
since many saw the clear subtext in the show that
she had a romance with Gabrielle, played by Renee
O'Connor. In fact, their relationship was going to
be the main focus of a new "Xena" reboot in 2015
from "Lost" alumni Javier Grillo-Marxuach for NBC.
Grillo-Marxuach wrote on his Tumblr page in 2016,
"There is no reason to bring back 'Xena' if it
is not there for the purpose of fully exploring a
relationship that could only be shown subtextually
in first-run syndication in the 1990s."
He also noted that the reboot would had some
kind of social relevance in its story, saying,
"It will also express my view
of the world — which is only
further informed by what is happening right now."
Unfortunately, in 2017, Grillo-Marxuach
parted ways with the "Xena" reboot,
due to creative differences with NBC. However,
Grillo-Marxuach told The Mary Sue that he remains
hopeful "Xena" will return to the screen
at some point in the future, explaining,
"I truly hope that the alchemy of creative
elements that has to come together to make
possible either a reboot or revival of this
amazing property will someday coalesce."
When the news broke that the "Xena" reboot
wasn't going forward at NBC, the network's
former Entertainment President Jennifer
Salke explained to The Hollywood Reporter,
"Nothing is happening on that right
now. We looked at some material;
we decided at that point that
it didn't warrant the reboot."
However, it wasn't all negative, as Salke pointed
out that "Xena" is a "beloved" property that might
be rebooted some day. It all depends on who's
at the helm of the reboot, as Salke explained,
"I'd never say never on that one because it's such
a beloved title, but the current incarnation of it
is dead [...] I need someone to come in with
a point of view about what they want to do."
In 2018, the pilot script for the reboot leaked
online to the Xena Movie Campaign Facebook page,
but fans in the comments were disappointed
about what the script contained. For instance,
one user lamented that Hercules had been changed
into a "heartless mercenary" in the script. Others
felt that it had potential, especially where
Xena and Gabrielle's relationship was concerned.
Fans also pointed out that a new "Xena" project
without Lucy Lawless wouldn't feel right.
As for whether the star would ever come
back to the role, the answer is yes.
And we all have "Terminator: Dark
Fate" to thank. Lawless told Yahoo!
Entertainment in July 2019 that seeing
Linda Hamilton return as Sarah Connor
made her wonder why she couldn't do
the same with Xena. She revealed,
"I saw Linda being amazing, and I'm like,
'Why can't we do that?' Bring back me
and Renee [O'Connor] and reboot Xena!'"
While Lawless did admit that filming all the
action wasn't her favorite part of making "Xena:
Warrior Princess," she said she'd happily
do it for a big-screen project, explaining,
"I always hated the action, and I don't
want to live that life. But for a movie,
I can do a little bit."
Lawless even suggested that
a cinematic outing for Xena
could easily set up a brand-new hero, explaining,
"[If] it's about handing over the baton to Junior
Xena or whatever — if you need mine and
Renee's help to do that, let's talk."
Lucy Lawless is in, and so are the fans. NBC
just needs to find a writer with a new vision.
"Sounds simple enough."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.